former white house adviser stephen
miller is leading the fight against that
his group is american first legal he
joins us tonight steven miller thanks so
much for coming on for being one of
the few people to mount a legal
challenge to all of this so what exactly
are you fighting against and why
well let's take new york first so we've
all heard the term equity thrown around
a lot in recent years what does it mean
equity means
using raw societal power
to punish people based on skin color
that's what equity is in the context of
new york we are seeing decisions about
life and death medical care being made
according to race and skin color
if this is allowed to survive if this
policy is allowed to endure
then in a very real sense our
constitution ceases to be the supreme
law of the land and instead becomes the
relic of a fallen civilization that's
how big the stakes are in this fight if
you get to the point in this country
where health care for your loved ones
for your family for your children your
grandparents can be decided based on
what country their ancestors come from
what they look like what their skin tone
is the american experiment is dead so
we're asking all new yorkers all new
york doctors who have concerns about
this policy to go to our website
aflegal.org get in touch with us help us
fight back legally and we're going to
see what we can do here
yeah i mean it it's this is so grotesque
that i have to believe if it were
covered if news organizations reported
that this was happening the average
person even the average biden voter
would say well you can't you can't kill
people because that's what they're
proposing withholding life-saving
medical care from people because of
their skin color that's like everything
we're against isn't it i thought
it means unlimited government power the
power of life and death over innocent
people because of how they look
you were talking about fascism there's
no other word to describe this this is
fascism american liberalism small it's
also racism i mean just to note the
obvious right i mean like yeah
it's racist fascism it's using
totalitarian power to advance a racist
agenda american liberalism small l the
idea of the individual having innate
dignity a net worth and innate rights
that's dead that's gone if this is
allowed to persist and ultimately spread
across our whole health care system so
that's what's at stake so again if
you're living in new york tonight and
you're concerned about how this policy
affects your health affects your
family's health health go to aflegal.org
where we are going to help you fight
back
no one else is doing it so i'm glad that
you are stephen miller thanks so much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else